there are other questions you've got a
lot of questions as well but I'm just
going to start off with a very open
question to the people here today and
I'm going to start off and I'll just go
from my immediate right and I work all
the way down to Dr Beryl at the end
that's a Tumblr
um I'm just going to ask you what your
message is for the world economic
foreign very nice to see you thank you
very much indeed for joining us today
thank you for being here and thank you
for yeah
um so we we are right now in Davos where
the
basically the people who are mostly
fueling the destruction of the planets
the people who are at the very core of
the climate crisis the people who are
investing in fossil fuels etc etc
um and yet somehow these are the people
that we seem to rely on solving our
problems where they have proven time and
time again that they are not
prioritizing that they are prioritizing
itself
self-grade corporate greed
um and short-term economic profits above
people and about planets and we are
listening we seem to be listening to
them rather than the people who are
actually affected by the climate crisis
the people who are living on the front
lines and
and that's that kind of tells us the
situation how absurd this is
um so with the people who who we really
should be listening to are are not here
instead we are bombarded with messages
from people who are
who are basically the people who are
causing this crisis
well for me
um
coming here I I didn't know exactly what
my message would be because what haven't
we said and what haven't we done what
haven't we you know communicated enough
the climate crisis is evidence in the
areas that are most impacted most cases
these areas are least responsible for
the crisis where people are stretching
their livelihoods people are trying to
survive clinging to you know clinging to
their lives and just trying to make it
for another day to make it for another
week to make it for another hour another
minute
so for me
my message is the climate crisis was
beyond statistics and data points it's
about the people and very soft and in
this place there is a disconnection
between you know what is being discussed
and what is happening on the ground
there is a a mismatch between
how people understand you know the
agency of the crisis here and what is
happening in places like turkana one of
the regions that is being impacted by
the drought in the Horn of Africa which
I was able to visit last year and I I
met different mothers different children
children that are suffering from Syria
are acute to malnutrition and it is
devastating to continue to see what the
climate crisis is doing to communities
and doing to children and different
matters across the world and one
specific
child that stood out for me is a child
that I met with his grandmother in a
hospital where cases of severe acute
malnutrition are required
and I remember reaching the grandmother
and I explaining how
you know it took them long to find the
treatment
and by the time they brought you know
the child to the hospital he was in a in
a western situation as described by the
doctors and the nurses and
she was just praying that the childhood
survive and
I mean a few hours later we learned that
this child had
passed away and
this could have been our preventable
deaths and
a preventable crisis so
I feel
um
frustrated too
I just I don't know what else to say
because
the agency of the crisis is evident and
people are dying
it's like a leaders are playing games
and they don't see the challenges
happening I am frustrated and
I'm so hyped by
what is happening and the inaction why
is it so hard for people to understand
the agency of what is happening
we could save very many very very many
lives because so many people are
stretching to try and survive the next
minute the next hour the next week the
next day and
hear the discussions on abroad
development
why don't we slow down a bit and talk
about life and
people it's just frustrating
um I come from an indigenous community
in the Amazon rainforest and for decades
we've seen how our forest has been cut
down again in the name of development uh
in for oil exploration for extractivism
the same industry that has caused the
climate crisis is also destroying our
territories and while they're at it
they're also committing human rights
violations
um we don't see the sense of urgency
reflected in action indigenous
communities indigenous peoples youth
scientists who've all been pointing
towards a direction uh where the oil
industry is is they're not going there
they're not going there the war leaders
are not going there and something that
Vanessa said
like we're frustrated but what else what
else uh can can we do we've said
everything we've we've done everything
we can uh and you know
um and and still we're going into this
really really dangerous dangerous direct
direction we're taking a really
dangerous path and we're already seeing
how people are suffering on the ground
we we see that every day in our lives
and and uh you know it's
um it's completely insane that uh we are
allowing this and we have people here in
Davos that are enabling that uh through
government through investing in the
fossil fuel
um and and at some point there there
needs to be a stop this is Criminal uh
this is this is Criminal behavior and it
should be judged also as well
there we go
um yes I'm a climate Justice activist
from Germany and I spent the last week
with Greta and many others depending
um livelihoods against code diggers and
the Rhineland in Germany which is the
largest single source of CO2 of the
whole of Europe
and many people then said oh it's a
interesting change of scenery coming
from the mother nature to Davos whereas
we walked through
um the dirty map in Elizabeth and now we
are Davos witnessing 30 years being made
so I'm not sure how much of a change
that actually is
um Chancellor Schultz yesterday said
that the future belongs to Renewables
and I think there's one part of the
sentence that she left out which is the
future does not belong to the fossil
fuels and if we look at the business
plans however of the big thought of fuel
Industries worldwide 96 of oil and gas
industry
um plan to expand even though we know
that the science is very clear the the
numbers are very clear there cannot be
any fossil fuel expansion happening
everywhere yet the business plans and
the investment plans they tell a
different story
and what does it mean what kind of
message is coming from that and the
messages I think quite clear
the future will not belong to the fossil
fuel Industries but they won't lead into
their future themselves as long as
possible views get to make the rules of
the end of the fossil fuel era there
will not be a end of the fossil fuel era
someone will have to draw the line
someone will have to say enough is
enough and end the destruction on that
end and I think we can be certain here
will not come from the industries
themselves and it will not come from
slow plans to transition to somewhere
right now we see that across the world
an expansion and under
um and an attention is playing is being
planned when it comes to fossil fuels so
as long as fossil fuel Industries are
planning to expand someone else will
have to say no to that that's where we
turn into the eia that's where we're
turning to governments worldwide that's
why we're going through the streets
and we also know that as long as
investors like blackwork like Deutsche
Bank like Qatar who are the lead
investors of rwe who we fought against
last week as long as they plan to invest
in new fossil fuels they are on the
right on the wrong side here and maybe
they don't want to know that but we can
be very certain about that and we're not
going to shy away from spreading that
message look one thing that's very clear
is that seeing for very powerful
activists here on the outside of work is
very interesting but in terms of
bringing the dialogue with powerful
institutions such as the Ia I think it
is absolutely fabulous that a the four
of you are here but Dave Patty you have
come as well because not only are you
here and I think it's it's great you are
but you also got a view to what's going
on in there now the ladies have already
said that there is inaction going on
inside the halls of the Congress they
have already said that there is no sense
of action despite the words
despite we've just had cop 27 I was at
26 and we've got 21 uh 15. what how
different is what you're hearing here to
the same urgency in there
and it takes uh Steve because of what
many texts is called the imitation I
think me being here is already a very
important thing that I wanted to give
the word
what America's first six first metaphors
takes to object to a greater
thank you very much
what you have been doing
see my messages are following
energy is responsible for about 80
percent of the emissions causing climate
change okay
we are not able to transform the energy
sector
we have no chance whatsoever to reach
our climate targets so we have to
transform the energy sector making it a
clean making it secure
and when I look at the uh today the
international agenda the global agenda
including here in Dallas
why do we have to see that the climate
change needs to get more attention
unfortunately the attention to climate
change is sliding down
I find it a rather very and it is the
reason I thought it is not time to Ring
the Alarm pass and bring the climate
crisis together with other crisis the
energy crisis food classes at the top of
the international policy agenda and I
think this is my main message climate
agenda yet it is a priority in the
agenda of the decision let me just get
some history because
um
the activists believe there can be no
new fossil fuels projects in order to
hit 1.5 degrees
you believe there should be no more
fossil fuel
um exploration production new facilities
to reach 1.5 degrees why is it that the
most preeminent organization perhaps
globally certainly amongst consumer
Nations is saying that and yet new
production is going ahead
so uh Steve the issue is we have to keep
the temperature increase to 1.5 degrees
Celsius
it was about that the leather fragile
equilibrium of our planet will be
distorted we'll be all in trouble
in order to do that we need to get
energy from clean carbon-free energy
sources
okay and to do that
the magic word is investment
today in lesson premium energy today the
world invests about 1.5 trillion dollars
in order to be in line with our climate
targets it needs to go to 4 trillion
dollars
in energy Investments and most of them
need to come from the developing
countries hopefully with the help of the
rich Advanced countries
now if we do that if we bring our energy
from clean energy sources
that we don't need any more coal we
don't need any more oil and gas new
investment stuff but the point of
departure is making clean energy
Investments and having a clear secure
Energy Future for all and there is
enough money to advice there's enough
capital
what we have to do is capital and clean
energy projects especially in developing
countries need to meet and what is
missing in my view is the international
political view if it was there this
would happen because we have enough Sun
we have enough wind and electric cars
are growing there's a lot of
technological innovation and we have a
lot of potential to see the cleaning
energy to dominate but unfortunately
what we are seeing today is there is a
transition happening but not at the case
that we would like to see especially
once again in the emerging and
developing world thank you fancy Greta
you have spoken inside the Realms of the
god process you have spoken outside of
the unfccc process you have been inside
where talking and now you're outside
I've done a lot of work just looking at
what the way you've changed and you just
seem to be on the outside now rather
than talking to people on the inside and
I think that's a great shame because
I've explained to some amazing people in
here the last week including the
Pakistan Minister for climate change who
was incredibly powerful about a thousand
kilometer leagues that just appeared
about Farmers having to deal with 50
degree plus heat as well do you not feel
that you're very strong voice actually
would continue to do good work if you
were actually talking to those powerful
people and to those people and just
giving them some leadership
well
first of all there are already activists
doing that and and I think that if there
should be activists in in inside
speaking to these people it should be
those on the front lines and not
privileged people like me who are not
experiencing the first-hand consequences
of the climate crisis yeah but then
again
um I think that's right now the changes
that we need are not
um very likely to come from from the
inside rather I believe they will come
from from the bottom up so to speak and
because without public pressure we have
massive public pressure from the outside
at least in my experience and these
people
are going to go as far far as they
possibly can as long as they can get
away with it they will continue to
invest in fossil fuels they will
continue to to throw people under the
bus for their own gain
um so I believe that the changes we need
right now needs to happen on the outside
we need to build and create a critical
mass of people who demand change who
demand Justice
um and of course we can do that also
from from the inside of it yeah
Ecuador is offering its own concerns and
deforestation and oil groups and gas
groups just tell us again where you see
the the campaign going forward because I
think many of us feel that we have to be
pragmatic in terms of working with and
understanding the pressure from the
outside as well how do you see the
campaign going forward
I I completely agree with with Greta but
we need to build massive movement of
people that are demanding change in our
demanding Justice
um
and when we are talking about the you
know energy transition we were talking
about the green transition we also need
to make sure that that is just I think
that's really really important that we
have
um voices uh from the places that are
being affected both by climate change
but also by the place uh what what the
energy transition would mean for for our
communities on the ground vulnerable
communities
um and and and I think that perspective
really needs to be taken into account by
the private sector and then it's a
perspective that uh cannot be left out
because if we do that we're leaving out
people again like just like we've done
um during you know the the entire
climate crisis
um and I would like to
um with together with Greta Vanessa
Louise and I we've credit created a
cease and desist letter
um to
oil CEOs
urging the oil CEOs to face out from new
fossil fuel
um they we know that they knew there's a
report that's come out saying that they
knew uh way before us what they were
doing when they were exploring for oil
they knew what the consequences would be
of CO2 gas emissions they knew the
irreversible consequences that huge
impact it would have on people's
livelihood if the huge impact it would
have on the environment
um we launched this a couple of days ago
and we're almost reaching 900
000 signatures which really shows the
commitment of Youth what really shows
the commitment of civil society and
people and the change that we are
demanding
um and this is a message to to these uh
CEOs and physician makers of how
urgently we want and we need change
anyway I am very happy to see that this
message is in fact aligned with what the
eia says very clearly that there cannot
be any trusted fuel um expansion
happening anywhere philosophy Industries
had 40 years time to prove that they
have to do anything good they clearly
failed and so um the message is very
clear and this is not just clear to us
activists it is clear to people
everywhere especially those fighting um
at the front line so we are very happy
for you
um to be here today and and we would
very much invite you to carry on this
message with us Mr Bureau
18th of May 2021
then we make the clean transformation of
the available energy sector next year
2050 we made our report so we are very
happy to see that the there will be a
big increase hopefully for clean energy
Investments not forcing Investments so
that we can both have energy because
energy is a good thing what is bad is
the emissions so we have a good energy
and we are going to reduce emissions and
the impact on the land so I am very
happy that the the our activists
colleagues here are pushing this agenda
forward Louise let me just come back to
you a little gentle pushback as well
because I I I understand what's been
going on that's why that's why and I
understand why you were there as well
but when you look at the longer message
from Schultz he said the following we're
going to be 100 energy from renewable
sources by 2035. wind and solar to reach
80 by 2030 Germany will be climate
neutral by 2045 this is a good
progression this is a good result in
many ways
there are other crises going on in the
world the catchphrase there and they
love a catchphrase here at uh where is
poly crisis keeping the lights on in
Europe fighting against the Russians in
Ukraine as well this has created new
Dynamics and other crises and I
understand what all of you are saying
including Patty about climate
initiatives slipping down the agenda but
actually the short-term remedies to
actually keeping the lights on in Europe
action had to be made and I know you're
going to push back again excellent
question well what we see isn't really
the climate movement started and really
emerging at a different scale across the
globe there has been a response by
leaders and that was a friendly message
to the pr departments for more green
headlines and so we are very well aware
that leaders across the world and also
Mr shows they they know their vocabulary
and they know you know where something
Net Zero has to happen and something
green has to you know be put out
um but we don't say listen to the super
science
um for a joke we say a and I think that
is clear to people across the world what
effectively counts as the numbers it's a
science and when we look at what is
behind all those big promises and many
in many cases and that is the case in
Germany what we see is a is a public
breakup with the Paris agreement that is
being performed and when I look at
countries like Germany we are on the top
five of global you know of the top
polluters worldwide there are a few
countries that are as responsible as
Germany and the G7 of course who would
return to if it comes to stick into
pledges made in Paris who are others
countries are we expect to provide the
finance to provide the industrial
transformation if not those countries if
they don't you know start to deliver and
so um yeah luckily enough the science is
clear the numbers is clear and we don't
have to be fooled anymore and people are
rising up everywhere just the other week
there were 30 000 people protesting with
us against the extension of the coal
mine with support from across the world
and we're really seeing that the pr
strategy that hoped you could just
marked away the climate crisis is not
working out whereas the people are there
and they are willing to tell the truth
I think we
today we can have some
slime Optimus legitimate optimism here
because last year 2022
the amount of renewed capacity coming to
markets was the record high we have
never seen such so much religious coming
around the world very good efficiency
improvements very strong and a lot of
Clean Energy Technologies are growing
the issue is there are two issues here
one they are not going fast enough they
should be to be in love with 1.5 the
second for me the nerve center of the
problem the emerging and developing
countries from Africa in Asia and Latin
America
it is a I think a moral responsibility
of the advanced economies to support the
clean energy transition in the emerging
world this is key to my view I
absolutely agree and I want us to
necessarily an aggressive question is
different questions Vanessa um one of
the key parts of the unfcc process and
the cop 27 has been that actually
financing for developing nations is
being seen as absolutely key to the
success we can't just have the rich West
uh finding Renewables if there isn't
support for the developing nations are
you seeing any evidence of that on your
travels and of course your your
heartbreaking experiences is there any
evidence that some of those promises are
getting to Ground Zero
well um I can speak from the most
recently established to a sun damage
fund
um I've called 27. it's it was
established but it's still an empty
bucket with no money at all and you know
coming here at Davos again
um you mentioned something about the
energy crisis keeping the lights for
Europe and you know the West I
understand that this is not the West
economic Forum this is the world economy
forum and many times the discussions
about the interests of
the you know the Western countries how
can we ensure that we address this you
know in Europe how can we ensure that we
address this but then there's been an
ongoing energy crisis for example
um in the global South and African
continent for decades with over 600
million people with no access to basic
electricity so I think that this really
needs to be treated like a wild of wild
economic front because I think the world
doesn't only constitute of Europe and
you know the West in general so I just
really wanted to say something on that
previous question that you asked that
is there is an energy crisis it's not
just in Europe it has been there for
tickets and we need the you know massive
scale up of Renewables
um
especially in communities that are
experiencing energy poverty all that
have been experiencing energy poverty
for decades so yes there is a need for
that Finance for adaptation there is a
need for real money for loss and damage
because with whatever you know crisis
that
um
we'll see
um it's already
it's already
um
it's multiple in the countries for
example in the global South and even the
discussions of you know 1.5 you know as
the ultimate space of survival but
um at 1.2 degrees it's already a living
hell for so many communities across you
know the African continent across the
global South so when we hear you know
discussions of 1.5 as you know the place
that will save us all maybe it's a place
that will save the you know the Western
countries but at 1.2 it's already
catastrophic for so many communities and
that's why it's really important that
you know we can't have any new fossil
fuel investment the U.N Secretary
General Attorney Richard has announced
that the business models of
fossil fuel companies are inconsistent
with human survival they're inconsistent
with human existence he already said
it's more an economic Madness to make
any of these Investments so to ensure
that people are protected not just in
the west but that the entire world we
must phase out on fossil fuels and let
us go oil and gas and massively support
a transition to renewable energy
especially much
every second person doesn't have access
to electricity it's number one number
two two out of three households using
primitive cook stores for cooking
which creates a lot of respiratory
diseases especially for women and
children and it is the top three
premature death reasons in substance
Africa this can be solved this problem
both of them access to clean electricity
and excessive Technique Cooking with a
very small amount of money enough money
to pay a one LNG terminal in one country
you can solve the problem in uttars of
southern Africa just to put in the
context of course I think the only
challenge is that we are only discussing
about the energy crisis and like I've
said
um
you know we often we don't talk about
Africa a lot I I really picked that and
I think it's really problematic because
it's like Africa is an after it's an
afterthought or
you know so
um we're busy focusing on
privileged countries while living out
communities that have been suffering for
decades the world doesn't revolve it's
only around the West yeah and it's not
just Africa or the west or developing
versus develop because the ramifications
in terms of migration and social which
will affect the whole world it can be
designed to regreta a very difficult
question is how should the developing
World be allowed to develop should we
actually allow well not allow allow but
should it be okay for developing nations
to use coal to use oil to use gas to use
fossil fuels so they can industrialize
so they can keep the lights on so they
can provide these stocks for agriculture
it's very tricky to know what developing
Nation should be able to do rather than
again the rich west of this
concentration of a lot this topic has
been about
first of all I think of the term
developing countries for this misleading
it's not like they are underdevelopers
where they are over exploited by other
countries
um like
like ours and I don't think I'm in the
position to tell others what to do
um when I mean the economic crisis boils
down to Justice and and what's already
happened this is a cumulative crisis and
what we do and the emissions we emit
stay in the atmosphere for a very very
long time and will continue to
destabilize the biosphere for many many
generations to come and of course not
only environmental effects but also thus
people
um so who am I to to say that I've had
these privileges
um but now others that haven't been able
to to do so shouldn't because we are
facing a a crisis and so on of course
that's
what the very roots of this crisis is
this mindset that some people are
are more worth than others and so on
that we
we seem to be sacrificing people
um
and this just
the thing that this does is that it only
puts and the so-called Western World in
in even more responsible
um position no no response but you get
what I mean we have even an even bigger
responsibility yeah yeah
um because to compensate and to make
sure that Equity is is um is at the
heart of climate action we cannot
continue to overlook these
these effects and it needs to be
embedded in every conversation every
discourse and yet it is still completely
absent
thank you right okay we have a limited
amount of time left um I'm seeing all
the hands going up this gentleman's been
very patient he's supposed to stand up
four times as well and if you just tell
everybody who all your news organization
who you are and then direct your
question thank you David gave us New
York Times this November cup 28th will
be hosted in the United Arab Emirates
one of the world's largest oil producers
and the UAE has selected its head of its
state-owned oil company as the head of
the proceedings Greta what does that say
to you about the proceedings about cop
and how does it affect your expectations
about what we can expect
um Greg is just honestly if we can make
this an open question maybe one of you
want to answer maybe you could give a
conclusion of it as well but um
Louisiana do you want to pick up
word up is it's ridiculous
um and it's not new though we've seen
the last cup in Egypt and how positive
lobbyists throughout that space so why
should that change if you know nobody
um who was in the position of power
demands those places to be working
towards Justice and not just towards
more Lobby deals
I just think it sends a message also
where where we're headed right now for
putting the heads of fossil fuel
companies to lead uh you know climate
negotiations we've had them investing
and uh in in cops for decades now and
we've seen where that has led us which
is nowhere
um and there's a huge interest of
conflict there uh and it's it just sends
this message of actually not taking it
seriously and it's I think it's exactly
what they're doing they're not taking
this seriously
I mean lobbyists have been influencing
these conferences for since basically
forever and this just puts a very clear
face to it
um
yeah exactly as previous hundreds have
said it's completely ridiculous
um
my name is
in favor of exploiting new gas resources
off the coast of synagogue
and he argues
countries to get
to get whole power plants what do you
think of them arguments
now first of all as I said Africa we
have to look at Africa very very closely
now in terms of electricity generation
I believe almost all the new electricity
generation in the sub-sahan Africa needs
to come from the University which is
cheap especially solar
let me give you one statistics which I
find really uh disturbing
as I said today in sub-Saharan Africa
one out of two people have no
electricity number
two substance Africa is 40 percent of
the global solar radiation very rich
and number three the solar is the
cheapest source of electricity
generation in Africa yet
yet
today the amount of solar power capacity
in sub-Saharan Africa is the cellular
complex one-third of the solar power
capacity in Belgium
take off the map global map how big is
the subscribe to how many people live
there and how big is a value so from
that point of view there is a huge
potential for electricity generation in
sub-Saharan Africa having said that
there are some applications because the
energy you don't need only for
electricity generation you need for
other things food processing
destination of water for these things
you may need a
can create high temperature heat and
here you can use gas
and here I would like to say that it as
Africa's share in global emissions is
three percent today
if even if I don't think that it will
happen but even if Africa would develop
all these natural gas resources it will
only go to 3.4 percent so from that
point of view I would be very careful to
put Africa in a different context than
other countries you can't compare Africa
with other countries thank you
um let's get a question from this lady
out of here
hi um live on my TV news this is for Dr
Beryl
um we know that uh Banks despite their
Net Zero pledges continue to fund new
oil and gas extraction what's the iea's
um view on this is it problematic so
which is their money
is money but I think I've seen three
risks there
and because Banks and others are saying
they are putting this because of the
energy crisis we are in the first risk
is if you today decide even deserve
today to build a new oil field the first
oil will come to the market in six seven
years of time if you not come tomorrow
there is a delay here it will not be
immediately already this is number one
number two
I am not sure I am not sure seven years
of time the global oil demand will still
increase and we will need more oil in
the future because the electric cars are
growing very strongly that will not be
demand so that may be a business risk
for those Banks this is the second uh
policy and the third point is it is a
climate risk from this three point of
view the timing doesn't justify the uh
this uh energy class it doesn't justify
this seven years this is a business risk
and there is a also the climate crisis
in general the pharmacy
uh one shouldn't imagine
to justify the
Russian invasion of Ukraine as some
large-scale fossil fuel Investments
largely used as an excuse
um I just got a question from this
gentleman here has been very patient
thank you hi everybody
my name is
scared in the foreign
and I guess my question is which
direction do you plan to take I think
there are two major weapons for
um to to avoid as unnecess on your
T-shirt these little Bridges as they are
caused into nowhere
um one is capitalism to the feeding the
oil and gas industry with its own
weapons meaning with cheaper wind energy
especially in the south of the world but
apart from that but I think that that's
one way to go the other is litigation
there's a lot of focus investigation so
my question is where does Friday's where
do you intend to go to make sure that
you influence influence stays high so
what I'll do is just to say I've got
time for one more question after this so
one of you I'm not looking yet and what
I want to do is if I may solve all of
you answering that question if you would
as well and I'll solve it with you if
you will do ASAP we take another
question to answer to maybe or not well
you've got two questions there anyway
are you going to the navigation route or
whatever route forward
well I think it's very clear that
um as an activist what we do we do what
we do not because it's easy or because
it's convenient because of that because
it's necessary and
um we don't do what despite it's hard
but because it's it's hard and it's a
tough um run and what we see though is
that we are joined by forces across the
globe and that could be enough we are um
more than ever and we see the most
unlikely alliances are building up and
speaking of the protest and the in the
cold area in Germany we were going for
Farmers by Churches by grandparents by
people from really um across the place
who will start understanding that that
this is their time to act and the idea
that you know the climate activeness
will save us oh it's a it's another myth
um to reassure in a time when there
can't be reassurance on things so I
think it's a very important message and
speaking of someone who has successfully
sued their own government I think
litigation of course is something that
we will look at and again and again
again this is a letter to season assist
and I think looking at the at the legal
context of that
um yeah and it is of course there are
more threats
um that can be taken um there which I
think is very important I would just
like to maybe say one more thing about
solving prices because I came up from
from UCF but also from the audience
it's a fairy tale to tell that fossil
fuels that new fossil fuels will solve
any kind of Crisis the energy crisis
we're in is the fossil fuel energy
crisis it is existing only because of uh
singular dependency on fossil fuels of
this particular fossil fuels from Russia
and what we're seeing is that new fossil
fuels don't solve energy crises in
Europe
but they produce crises across the globe
and whenever someone goes ahead and
starts selling a new fossil fuel project
as a solution to any kind of Crisis I
think it's a journalistic duty but also
a public duty to challenge this and to
ask
um what kind of Crisis to be solved and
which new crisis is to be produced here
which as we heard on the panel is very
obvious I think that's something here
very quickly I think the lasting
solution to our energy classes go to
clean energy Investments
I think the reason why we do this is
because we know we have so many
by coming I come from the rainforest and
living there when I go back here I go
back to a clean River so I go back to a
rainforest they're standing that is
living that is healthy I go back to a
people that have been fighting for
decades I have that and I have something
to defend but I do can assure you is
that we will be excuse my French a pain
in the ass for everyone who's working
towards uh the new exploration of fossil
fuels and destroying our planet and that
I think I sleep for all thank you
well I think that you know one of the
challenges that I see is that there's so
many people saying that they need us
there's so many people saying we are
inspiring there's so many people giving
stunning Ovations but few of them are
joining us in our fight for climate
justice so I think that as we move
forward
um I mean
activists are expected to be strong and
all that but it can be frustrating you
know it can be frustrating to see the
inaction and to see the crisis continue
to impact so many people so I think we
need to move from a place of being told
that we are needed
to people joining us and working with us
in you know whatever space that you're
in if it's
in the lord it's in the schools if
you've seen media whatever thing that
you can do like play A Part in our fight
for yeah
I mean we are nowhere near the end we
have only just begun
um but no one said that this was going
to be easy it's um we know that the
changes that we are advocating for are
not going to happen overnight
um and um that is why we
we have to stay strong during a longer
period of time but also we cannot do
this on our own the climate activists
currently need to multiply many times we
need many many more because we
I mean we need we need help right now we
are still moving in the wrong direction
we are speeding in the wrong direction
the global measures of greenhouse gases
are still increasing we are heading
completely we need many many more so we
urge everyone to to join the fight okay
I've got time for one short question
um I'm gonna let the lady and one should
ask a question and I guess very briefly
honest because I know you're all going
to move on as well so this I didn't know
really quickly the inflation reduction
Bloomberg the inflation reduction Act is
getting a lot of attention here at
Grabbers this week in other nations and
global leaders are countering that
legislation with their own what do you
make of that legislative on climate
change is that effective
um why didn't you start off what you see
positive or negative in the IRA and then
we'll just move on and just ask if if
this want to comment on this one as well
I I was uh first of all I should say is
Steve and if I am a man who makes his
hands dirty with data every single day
is you know the energy data and I have a
a definitely a view of a legitimate
optimism as far as the cleaning energy
is concerned today
it is growing but the problem is that
it's not going fast enough to reach our
climate targets so it is not something
that it is stopping it is growing now
in addition to the all of the market
forces government decisions and so on
the inflation reduction Act
in my view is a very transformative move
from the United States giving about 400
billion dollars
president Barton and is a government to
clean energy sources
so that it is built this electric cars
it is clean hydrogen and others so
therefore I hope other countries and an
Indians moving in the same direction I
hope Europe will come with a response to
at least a clean energy they all
together have to reach our clean energy
goals so this is my hope an influence
reduction Act is a step in that
direction so it's it's a it's a public
sector coming up with the carrots as
well as stickers they want to comment on
what's happening in the US government
and what you hope other governments to
do in terms of incentivizing companies
to look for more green initiatives
I think we do now yeah okay right um why
don't ask a very final question then and
I believe literally want a 10 second
answer for all of you as well I do want
to end this and try and say is there
anything that you're seeing at the
moment I can tell you what I'd see is
optimistic but I'll tell you afterwards
as well do you see anything at the
moment going on that gives you a course
for optimism we'll just go down the line
very quickly
um the people standing up addressing
their voices against the answer that is
happening that's the Hope right now
they'll come from the people that's
so
hello
yeah I think that they were excellent
dashboards I think we keep each other at
the powers with the people and as great
as that we urge many many more to join
um the term activist itself hopefully
doesn't need to exist um at some point
anymore because people have understood
that standing up for right and for the
right to live and for lovely it
shouldn't be an act of activism but
um yeah the most common thing
maybe I can add to the people one night
also people on the ground are not giving
up they're still putting up
hell of a fight fatty calls for optimism
Steve what I see this challenge is
really very huge transformation entire
energy structure which has been in place
decades and decades
and to do that in addition to technology
government support and so on with
advantage in my view most important
to to bring together a grant Coalition
of the people who are genuinely
interested to tackle climate change
those governments Civil Society
companies who are genuinely interested
to address tackle climate change and I
think this grant Coalition is solved but
surely and this gives me an optimism and
that is in the fact that we've got one
of the most powerful men in energy
sitting on a panel with all the most
powerful activists in climate change so
I just want to thank all of you Dr fatty
Beryl thank you very much indeed good to
see you again Elizabeth thank you very
much Helena really nice to meet you
Vanessa in the cafe incredibly powerful
I mean thank you very much Dave I'm glad
to come here as well thank you very much
indeed for joining us
[Applause]